I am
saw a tool concert I've seen a couple
but the 1996 in Albuquerque New Mexico
Albuquerque
and no I was living there I was so
just I mean not not to crawl up your ass
and and you know smother it with kisses
but I think I think you're looking you
meant to say butthole yeah yeah all
right bring it back I mean there was um
like uh just like the the notes man like
the the like the recreate like there's
certain bands like just aren't great
live and and uh I've found tool to be
unbelievably Stellar live okay and uh I
mean I just
wanted to throw that out there that was
great
what's your point Steve yeah he did
great just let it let it go okay
now I felt my face turning red
hot like how has um performed like or
like it's been so many years now like uh
we you know old cars right they used to
like you know an old
uh Barracuda man just like tearing up
the streets you tried to do that with an
old Barracuda now and it's that's
gonna break something's right you know
it just you just can't do that so
think with age you find you find ways
to sing the thing where it's not
creating damage you can actually
recreate it without having to
pick a scab emotionally and literally
like hurting yourself so I think my
writing has changed over the years
um
and I can do some of those songs I can't
do a whole set of those songs right I
can pepper them in so I can still do
some of those things but I can't you
can't
if you're actually sitting down and
thinking about it you can you know you
can't expect
some of those dudes that you know back
in the day to do the thing they did when
they were 30 years ago 40 years ago that
you can't expect that out of that body
your body doesn't do those things
forever
you see the latest uh
latest it was like a year ago Mike Tyson
fighting yeah who do you fight Roy Jones
yeah so as much of a monster as that
dude is and I have all there's respect
in the world for Tyson watching him do
that it's like please please don't do
this ever again yeah because you can see
the age there's a there's a there's an
absolute expiration date on on that high
performance and then at the level that
that guy was operating at when he was in
his prime and to watch whatever that was
right if you don't get it by seeing that
that's the and I'm using him as an
example like that glaring example of
like that is an absolute expiration date
your net your your body is not going to
allow you to perform the way you used to
perform at certain ages so
you can apply that to pretty much
everybody when it comes to physical sure
that's why jackass is gonna be so funny
when they're 70. it's going to be like
the broken hip episode it's just break
in half um just talking about the stunts
and they break a hip going to get some
get a [__] yogurt for sure right uh
we I have found my bones to be
considerably more brittle yeah um at
this time and I had the same reaction to
the Mike Tyson fight and and I love Mike
um I was actually at his uh like the
little compound where where he does his
podcast the the Tyson ranch with a bunch
of friends and stuff and
I I felt the same way that you just
described but also it was like a
phenomenally successful event like yes
it wasn't so there's there's and and
that always ends up being the factor
um
money it's just
it twists [__] and you know if
many people that probably have their
hand out
to make money on that fight for Tyson
I'm sure they have their handout again
trying to talk him into doing another
one right when you as a viewer you
remember you see Anderson Silva connect
dude the other night uh San Hagen and
Cheeto those guys those guys are
lightning fast with those strikes right
and to watch Mike Tyson knowing how fast
he was and then see yeah you can
perceive the micro second delay that he
has to deal with now do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
Stevo's butt wipes for your butt hole
are available on Amazon and if you want
a real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now yeah
dude